[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA ESTHER WOLFSON:
Well, thank you very much,
everybody, for coming.
It's a tremendous honor
to be here at Google.
I'm really in awe of the
speakers who have preceded me
on this podium.
There are so many
writers and thinkers
and men and women of
action who have been
part of the Google Talk series.
Most of them have presented some
very specific area of knowledge
or even wisdom, or
they've talked about how
to do something in particular.
As a writer, what I have to
offer is story, and language,
and that's it.
There's not going
to be a take away
because art is the marriage
of content and form.
And form cannot be
retold or summarized.
So I'm going to read
to you from my book
"For Single Mothers Working
as Train Conductors," which
some readers and critics
have described as an essay
collection.
Some have said it's
a book-length essay.
Some call it a memoir.
That's my publisher because they
say that essay collection is
the marketing kiss of death.
Some call it a story
collection, but it really
is an essay collection.
But whatever you
call it, it takes up
a grab bag of subjects that
are obsessions for me--
translation, untranslatability.
I've actually forged a
new path in essay writing.
There are a lot of
essays about translation,
but I am the first
writer I know who
writes about not translating.
I realized after
this book came out
that it has two
essays in it that
are about books that I decided
not to translate and why.
And I haven't-- I have
another one in mind.
And I've been told that when
you write from your own life,
you will only ever
write one book.
This was something that a
writing teacher thundered at me
when I was young,
and I was turning
in a story that was
purported to be fiction
but clearly it was not.
But I think I found the
solution because if you write
about books you
have not translated,
you will never run
out of material.
So the obsessions that I take
up in this book-- translation,
untranslatability, Russian,
French, and Yiddish culture,
literature, and language.
I worked with French
and Russian at the UN.
I did not work with
Yiddish at the UN.
Other obsessions include
Judaism, marriage and divorce,
and chronic illness.
I'm going to tell
you this story, which
is one section of "For Single
Mothers Working as Train
Conductors," which is a highly
subjective even quirky account
of my experiences being
hired as a new staff
employee at the United Nations.
This piece takes up some
other subjects as well.
But they're all subsumed under
the heading of "The Resistance
and Grief That We Human Beings
Display When We're Unwillingly
Going Through Life Transitions."
And in this case,
it's the transition
from a high-flying
international career
as a diplomatic and
conference interpreter
of Russian and English to a desk
job requiring minimal knowledge
of a few languages
before I transition
into a job as a
translator working
with documents in Russian,
French, and Spanish.
Another transition it
describes is the transition
from the freedom
of self-employment
to being a tiny cog in
an immense bureaucracy.
And both of those
transitions were
occasioned by a
different transition,
which was the transition from
health to chronic illness.
Now this is a worm's
eye view of what
it's like to work at
the United Nations,
and it's not terribly favorable.
So I'll give you some
background, some context,
but before I get to
that, I want to say
that there is a kind of open
secret about my book, which
I'll share with you.
It's something that
authors are always
enjoined not to say about their
work, but I'm a debut author.
I haven't mastered the
protocols and the etiquette,
so I can say whatever I want now
until my second book comes out,
which I don't think
will be anytime soon.
This one took over a decade.
And that open secret is that
my book is autobiographical.
I don't know why this
is often associated
with shame for writers, and
many writers will do almost--
they will stand on their
head to avoid admitting this
even if it's true.
The pedigree of autobiographical
writing is superb.
Everything from Augustine's
"Confessions," "Lord,
make me chaste but not
yet," to "The Little
House on the Prairie," to
"Remembrance of Things Past,"
which you'll hear more
about in a moment.
These are some of
my favorite books.
But I cannot hide the fact that
my work is autobiographical.
It's transparently clear.
I live on the Upper
West Side of Manhattan.
My narrator lives on the
Upper West Side of Manhattan.
I worked as an interpreter and
translator of Russian, French,
and Spanish, and
my narrator worked
as an interpreter and
translator of Russian, French,
and Spanish.
I have a chronic
degenerative lung disease.
My narrator has a chronic--
well, you get the idea.
But even though it's won a
prize for literary nonfiction,
this book and my
writing in general
embraces subjectivity,
memory lapses, hearsay,
and speculation, and
as such it should not--
it cannot and should
not be fact checked.
Its purpose is to tell a
story, not to say here's
what happened.
I would compare it to a
re-touched photograph.
So getting back to
the United Nations,
I said I wanted to give
you some context because
of the unfavorable impression
that my reading may give you.
I believe in the United Nations.
I believe in its mission.
I believe in multilateralism.
But many of my UN coworkers
and I have a sneaking sympathy
for that famous remark
by John Bolton, who
was George W. Bush's ambassador
to the United Nations
when he said that if the top 10
stories of the United Nations
secretariat should
suddenly disappear,
nobody would miss them.
And our sympathy for
this remark has nothing
to do with our politics.
You would have to search
high and low to find
a staffer at the UN who
supported George W. Bush, let
alone Trump.
It has more to do with the
way the organization is
run sometimes.
The UN is in desperate
need of reform.
That reform will probably
never take place.
But it is nonetheless a really
necessary and indispensable
organization.
And one of the problems is
that because its ideals are
so lofty, when it
inevitably fails,
that failure seems even
greater than it is.
But to get back to
the top 10 stories
of the secretariat
building, I think
one of the reasons my
colleagues and I would not
be sorry if it
disappeared is because it
houses among many other things
the human resources department.
And to get hired at the
UN, which in my case
took several years, you have
to jump through so many hoops
and go through a
ridiculous gauntlet
to prove your qualifications.
I actually had to come in with a
rolling suitcase that contained
all of the books I had
translated so they could
estimate how many
words I had translated
during my previous decade
and a half as a translator.
And this kind of thing causes
people to start their work
at the UN already with an
enormous chip on their shoulder
toward their employer.
There are some good things at
the-- in the top 10 stories
of the UN.
There is a restroom that has
a stunning view of Midtown
Manhattan for women
only, although I'm
told that it's been used as
a viewing post to look down
on the roofs of lower
buildings nearby when
couples are trysting and they're
unaware that they're visible.
It also has a locked room
on the top floor reachable
only by a creaky,
twisting staircase
that contains nothing else
but a ping pong table.
And this is one flight up from
the Secretary General's office.
The ping pong table room is a
place where diplomats go late
at night when they're locked--
deadlocked I should
say-- in talks.
They bang the little ball
around to blow off steam
before they go back to the
negotiation table, one hopes,
to achieve better results.
So the UN does everything
it can to reduce
international tensions.
And in that connection, I do
think that the United Nations
is important and indispensable.
It's the only place in the world
where all 193 countries can
come together to
discuss everything that
needs to be discussed, from
sexual violence in conflict
to food insecurity to border
control, counter-terrorism,
how to stop female
genital mutilation,
and the human rights of women,
ethnic and racial minorities,
people with disabilities,
and children.
I don't agree with
those people who
say we should turn
our backs on the UN
and instead found an institution
that's for democracies only.
I think that would be
very, very problematic.
I think that the
non-democracies are precisely
the countries that need
to be kept in the loop
and in the discussion.
Furthermore, I'm not sure
who would decide which
countries are democracies.
Is the Democratic People's
Republic of Korea a democracy?
Some people obviously think so.
The Democratic
Republic of Congo,
also known as the
International Capital of Rape?
And then there are countries
whose democratic credentials
have been burnished
for centuries
that seem to be veering
toward other forms of rule.
And there are democracies that
become authoritarian, and then
one hopes return to democracy.
Are they going to join this
hypothetical organization
then be expelled and then
re-apply for admission
when they return to democracy?
So with these
unanswered questions,
I will now read to you
"Proust at Rush Hour."
There are two things you need to
know because this is not quite
at the beginning of the book.
It references the
lung disease which
I was diagnosed with in
the course of working
as a contractor at the UN and
undergoing all the processes
for becoming a staffer, and
it also references my bid
for that job, which was a bid
for financial and professional
security.
So "Proust at Rush Hour."
"My job is a drag like
most 9 to 5 gigs I imagine.
But, oh, the commute.
The commute is a golden border
at the beginning and end
of each workday that
sheds some of its shimmer
onto the leaden
expanse in between."
I should add that I wrote
this a few months after I
became a permanent staffer.
And I didn't realize
until a few years later
that it was actually
a lament for the lost
freedom of self-employment.
"But, oh, the commute.
The commute is a golden border
at the beginning and end
of each work day that
sheds some of its shimmer
onto the leaden
expanse in between.
I'm a New Yorker, so taking
the subway to work is a given.
The subway provides in
miniature all of the charms
of long-distance train
travel minus the view.
There is the unencumbered
time, a commodity
beyond price for those who sell
their waking hours in order
to afford a place to sleep.
There is the heady state of
in-betweeness, a brief release
from all worldly entanglement.
There is the fact that subway
travel is, for now at least,
incompatible with
email and cell phones
and that it will always be
incompatible with vacuuming,
dishes, and laundry.
There are about
half a dozen things
tops that you can
do on the subway--
doze, observe the people
around you, listen to music,
read, think, things we
should all do more often.
I was not always a commuter.
I used to be self-employed.
I worked from home.
And when I traveled,
my conveyance of choice
was the jet plane.
State banquets at the Kremlin,
Mafia trials, forgotten
literary masterpieces, KGB
files declassified under Yeltsin
to be reclassified later under
Putin, I translated them all.
It was a halcyon time.
The border between working
and not working was porous.
When work was slow, I took
a walk or a yoga class.
When a deadline loomed, I
worked weekends or evenings.
As to why people dreaded Monday
and thanked God it was Friday,
I lacked all understanding.
When people spoke
of their commutes,
I listened as to an account
of some quaint foreign ritual.
But in my mid-thirties,
panic bore down.
My health insurance was patchy,
my retirement savings meager,
my income blossomed and
shriveled with the seasons.
I began planning for the
transition from free spirit
to commuter, boning
up on my French
so as to get that job
I'd set my sights on.
Apart from the expense, there
was nothing onerous in this.
Who would object to
spending some months
in Paris immersed in the
language of Moliere and Serge
Gainsbourg.
This was a dream I had
nurtured and then set aside
almost 20 years before, and
I was glad of any pretext
to make it come true at last.
French mastered, I
prepared to take up
my new job as an interpreter
of Russian and French
into English, working in a
tall building of green glass
at Midtown Manhattan's
eastern edge.
And now unforeseen
things began to happen.
During the trial period
before the job was
to become permanent,
my newly failing lungs
made it difficult
then impossible
for me to perform that demanding
work, a seemingly firm job
offer went limp.
Through a series
of short contracts
within the organization,
I tumbled down and down
in status and job satisfaction,
though not salary.
Until I landed in a
permanent position
editing English-language
documents
with duties that called
for no more than a
passing knowledge of French
or any other foreign language.
Movement up the hierarchy,
I would come to understand,
was the reward for a different
sort of fluency altogether,
directly proportionate
to the climber's ability
to say nothing and offend no
one in the most elegant way
possible all at great length.
Shortly after I started
the permanent job,
I was copied on an email from
one higher-up to another,
its contents presumably
affecting my future
in some way that embodied
this style so utterly
that I would be remiss if I
did not reproduce it here.
Quote-- 'while I do not
think that your concern is
misplaced,' ran this missive,
'I would say that it may be
premature to suggest that
the guidelines would apply
uniformly as they
stand to all staff.
I hope I'm not being
overly sanguine about this,
but I tend to think that just
as our specificities are being
taken into account to a
large extent in the interim,
they would readily be
accommodated in the long term.
In other words,
the guidelines only
state the policy which
will no doubt allow
for some special dispensation.
However, I do not dispute
for a second that yours is
a legitimate concern.'"
When I got this-- this
is just an aside--
I didn't know what I
was going to do with it,
but it seemed like such a
fantastic example of something
that I printed it out to save.
And then later I
found this use for it.
"But I reminded myself as
I printed out the email
and taped it to the wall over
my computer between a map
of the economic community
of West African states
and another of the
former Yugoslavia--
the Yugoslav Republic of
Macedonia, I was lucky.
At last I had a permanent job.
It came with health
insurance, which saved me
thousands each month on
crucial prescriptions,
medical equipment rentals,
and doctor visits,
disability benefits if I
became unable to work--
a possibility I now
had to entertain--
dental coverage so dazzling
that even the receptionist
at the dentist's
office was impressed,
liberal sick leave of which
I would take full advantage,
a sunsplashed office with a view
of boats chugging up and down
the East River, access
to a post office,
bank, credit union,
employee-only low-interest
mortgages, medical service,
international newsstand, yoga,
dancercize, and Pilates classes,
a cappuccino bar, cafeteria,
fancy restaurant with enormous
bowls of whipped cream
and raspberries on the all you
can eat dessert buffet, nine
levels of instruction at no
cost in my choice of Spanish,
Arabic, or Mandarin,
and high school
choirs visiting from
the heartland, singing
songs of international
peace and brotherhood.
All this right on
the premises, all
mine in exchange for spending
my days doing nothing
or what felt like nothing.
Where would I find
something better?
Indeed, I often ask
myself that question.
Although my Russian and
my newly acquired French
are, as noted, superfluous in
the job where I've ended up,
the hiring process mysteriously
included an eight-hour language
proficiency test.
And just as mysteriously,
the word translator
figures prominently in my title.
With some luck in a few years,
I might transfer back to a post
where foreign languages
could prove useful.
In the meantime, I've decided
to read Proust, yes, "In Search
of Lost Time," also
known as "Remembrance
of Things Past," in the
original French, all of it,
seven volumes on the
subway standing up.
Here's the drill.
In the morning, I get
to the subway platform,
pull out the book,
and open to the page
where I left off the previous
evening when the subway
doors glided apart at my stop.
It's a fine edition with
the thinnest of paper,
the title tooled in
gilt on the spine,
and a slender grosgrain bookmark
sewn in, also gilt. Failure
to get the volume into
position before the train pulls
in means I may not get to do
any reading that morning as it's
often too crowded to fumble
in my bag for the book
after I board.
Other things to do before I
push my way onto the train,
lay my hands on a pen
in my bag and make
sure the sticky note inside
the book's back cover
has not come unglued
and fallen out.
The pen and the little
yellow scrap of paper
are for writing down
unfamiliar words.
If I don't have a
pen at the ready
or if the sticky note is missing
or already filled with scrawls
from previous commutes, I'll go
back later, reread the pages,
and write down the
unfamiliar words
that I didn't capture
on the first pass.
Then I'll look up--
look them up during
the slow moments
at the office that
add up to a work
day and another and another.
The office with
the river view is
awash in battered
foreign language
dictionaries that appear to have
languished there for decades.
If it weren't for
Proust and my compulsion
to look up every single
unfamiliar word I come across,
they would get very
little use indeed.
Here are a few entries
from my Proust word list.
[SPEAKS FRENCH]
Meaning respectively, sullen,
simpering, water sprite,
convoluted, mawkish,
carnation, jubilation,
tea party, to
warble, upholsterer,
villainy, procuress,
calling card, and greyhound.
I'm on the Seventh Avenue
express now hurtling downtown.
In one hand, I hold the
book and in the other,
the pen so I cannot properly
be called a strap hanger.
I assume a wide
stance, bend my knees,
and ride the train
like a skateboard.
In the 12 minutes or
so it takes the train
to barrel down the line from
96th Street to Times Square,
I fight inertia's pull toward
freefall into some stranger's
lap, plunging instead into
the bucolic village of Combray
or the Paris salons
and cafes, where
representatives of the haute
bourgeoisie and demimonde
cross paths.
I read Proust almost
exclusively on the subway.
On weekends, I rarely
pick up the book.
The little volume with
the grosgrain marker
lies untouched on my
desk from Friday evening,
time of unseemly
rejoicing, until Monday
morning, time of
dread beyond reason.
This runs counter to
my notion of myself
as someone with an almost
religious reverence
for literature and its greats.
But there it is.
My life yields up
few moments that
are conducive to the
concentration and discipline
that Proust requires.
Every week or two, I
indulge in a dalliance
with some other author.
This sometimes takes place
on the subway but mostly off.
When I read on the down
low, it's always in English,
no need to keep a running lookup
list with the attendant pen
and Post-it note,
usually the work
of some contemporary
author whose
style is relatively terse.
Though compared to Proust,
everything seems terse.
I can tear through
a contemporary novel
of 200 to 300 pages in
the time it takes to read
25 to 30 pages of Proust.
Read in brief spurts,
Proust's 3,000 pages--
well, the 700 I've read so far--
reveal themselves to be a
series of hundreds and hundreds
of linked discursive essays
two to five pages long.
Here is a description of a
bouquet of chrysanthemums
in Madame Swann's chambers,
which segues into mention
of a sunset whose color is
similar to the flowers, which
doglegs into a discussion of how
her former life as a kept woman
with a sideline in prostitution
nurtured in Odette, as she's
known to numerous
intimates, a taste
for a range of luxury
goods delivered to her door
from exclusive establishments
spanning many [SPEAKS FRENCH]..
Here is a discussion of the
difference between the face
a famous writers
presents at a dinner
party and his interior life
as laid bare in his books
and of the young
narrator's astonishment
at the contrast between
the two aspects of the man
whose work he has long
admired, a contrast
so marked that he thinks the
party guest must in fact be
some other writer
who coincidentally
bears the same name.
Here is a meditation
on a musical phrase
that lodges in Swann's memory
after repeating-- repeated
hearings.
Here is Times Square.
I almost missed it, engrossed
in a description of the acacia
trees and the public toilet
on the Champs Elysees
near where Marcel and
Gilberte play hide and seek
after school.
I pause mid-sentence, ride
the human wave off the train,
and come to rest
on the platform.
Later when I resume
reading, I will cast around
in the middle of a two-page
paragraph to find my place.
Although in a 300-page
stretch in which Proust places
under a microscope
the narrator's love
for his playmate, his pain when
he decides to cut himself off
from the girl because she
doesn't love him back,
his brief conversations
with her parents
when he visits her house
at hours carefully chosen
so that the girl will
not be there and hearing
about his visit later,
will perhaps be intrigued,
and how Odette
accessorizes the kimonos
she wears when receiving guests.
Whether I resume exactly
where I left off,
inadvertently skip ahead,
or re-read half a page
without realizing it right away
is of almost no consequence.
I come up the stairs and
cross a wide underground space
on my way to board the
shuttle to Grand Central.
And before I see
them, I hear them.
The warm, ludic sounds
evoke an involuntary smile.
I follow the music to the top
of the stairs, around the corner
and behind a wide pillar.
I stop to soak up the feeling
that rolls off these musicians.
They're playing a washboard,
a dulcimer, a fiddle,
a tambourine, cymbals,
drums, a banjo, and a bass
though not all at once as the
instrument-to-player ratio is
about two to one.
Dollar bills and CDs spill
out of an open guitar case.
The men are wearing odds
and ends reminiscent
of other worlds and times--
a bolo tie, a bandanna,
a striped railroad cap,
a cowboy hat, a stocking
cap pulled down low
over dreadlocks.
With them is a woman who wears
her excess flesh like an ermine
stole and passes out flyers
to the sparse audience, which
is constantly dispersing
and replenishing itself.
When she runs out of
flyers or audience,
she shimmies to the
music in a manner that
appears deeply introspective.
The flyers and the
handwritten sign
propped against
the instrument case
announced that these are
the Ebony Hillbillies.
The men are not young.
The calm they radiate
is not a natural fit
with Times Square at rush hour.
But utterly at home
in their music making,
they carry it off.
Their attitude captivates.
Kindly, never rushed, each one
engrossed in his own playing
and simultaneously
adjusting to his partners
in numerous infinitesimal ways,
they are doing their thing
and doing it to perfection.
Soon I will hasten toward
the low-cost mortgages,
the cappuccino bar, the
Arabic lessons, the Pilates,
and the raspberries
with whipped cream.
I'm always precisely 10 minutes
late, and no one in the office
ever seems to notice.
But for the moment,
I am swept up.
Where do these men
live, I wonder.
It's always the first
question a New Yorker asks.
Do they ride the A train
in from Far Rockaway?
Maybe they've come in from
Jersey City on the Path train.
Do they have day jobs, benefits?
I doubt that anyone has
ever gazed admiringly
at their dental insurance cards.
They play bass drum,
click, scrape, and saw.
One of them taps his toes.
Another stamps his heel.
A third does something like
singing but less melodious.
They do not look like the
kind of street musicians
who interrupt their
playing to bob their heads
and say thank you ma'am to
passers by dropping coins
in their case.
No, they are not that kind.
I stand off to the side,
watching and listening
for as long as I can before
running to make my connection.
I head for the shuttle,
which goes ceaselessly
back and forth between Times
Square and Grand Central.
I have my pick of three
trains on parallel tracks
numbered 1, 3, and 4.
They all go to the same place.
Someone once explained to
me why there's no track 2,
but I've forgotten the reason.
There's a track 2
elsewhere in the system,
but it peters out before
reaching Times Square,
something like that.
I clutch the little
volume in one hand,
preparing to open it and
regain my place mid-sentence.
Behind me, the men--
did they grow up together
somewhere in East Tennessee?
Did their group coalesce
in a bar in Brooklyn
before Brooklyn was hip?
Are they Harlem born and bred?--
are still at it?
On the shuttle, I'll
read one more page,
maybe two if I recognize
all the words about Odette
and the ladies who come to
her Wednesday afternoons
and discuss where they have
their dresses made or about
a brothel where
the madame always
urges Marcel to try out a Jewish
prostitute with messy hair.
She's better educated and
a better conversationalist
than the others says the madame.
And Marcel always demurs.
No, thank you.
Maybe next time.
I'll get off the
shuttle at Grand Central
with the other passengers
and traverse the station's
cathedral-like expanse.
There are easier,
faster routes to work.
But a day that brings
with it a sense of awe,
head tilted to take
in that vast space,
is a day not yet entirely lost.
I will admire the
pearly-faced clock
that anchors the center
of the Grand Hall,
go down a narrow
marble-floored passage
where vendors sell grilled
Hawaiian tuna, peppercorn
sausage, cheeses that
verge exquisitely
on the foul, mangoes, bananas
foster cupcakes, whatever they
are, tiramisu cake, and
other treats with names
fancy beyond recall
wrapped in crinkly paper
or packed in bright tins, and
dripping with snob appeal.
I will emerge from underground
into the city and the shadow
of the green glass building.
I cannot hear the
music anymore."
That's all folks.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll be happy to take
questions about anything
I just read or said or
anything about the book.
AUDIENCE: I have to ask,
did you ever finish Proust?
LAURA ESTHER
WOLFSON: Sorry what?
AUDIENCE: Did you
ever finish Proust?
LAURA ESTHER WOLFSON:
Did I ever finish Proust?
I am finishing Proust.
I'm still finishing Proust.
I'm on volume four.
I was reading volume
one in '07 I think.
So I put it down
for years at a time.
And the last time
I put it down, I
decided I should
reread the parts
that I had read in French.
I should read them in
English as a memory jog.
So that took a year.
And now I'm on volume four.
AUDIENCE: Seems like you learned
French at a later age and not
in school.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
How is that experience?
Harder?
What were your resources?
LAURA ESTHER WOLFSON:
What were my sources?
AUDIENCE: Resources.
LAURA ESTHER WOLFSON: Resources.
Well, I actually had a very
solid foundation in French.
I had taken it for five or
six years in middle school
and high school.
And I hadn't touched it or
used it in probably 20 years,
but it was all there.
It was just like opening a
book that had been closed.
The grammar was all there.
I just needed to be--
to learn how to
comprehend spoken French
and add vocabulary.
So I-- as a freelancer,
I was able to take time
to go to France and
take French classes
and mingle with French people.
And I had a mentor,
who was already
an interpreter at the
UN, who was coaching me
through this process,
and she told me
which newspapers to read,
what movies to go to,
what TV shows to watch.
Go to plays.
Find yourself a French-speaking
boyfriend, she said to me.
So that was how I did it.
It took about six months.
And it's important to note
that since I was working only
from French into
English, I didn't
have to be able to speak
flawlessly or write flawlessly.
I only had to
comprehend flawlessly,
and that's a
passive skill that's
much easier to acquire than
the active skills of speaking
and writing in other language.
And although there's a
widespread perception
that it's harder to learn a
language when you're an adult,
I don't think that's
necessarily true, especially
if you've already learned
a foreign language.
Then you have a lot of the
conceptual apparatus in place
already, and you just
need to add another layer.
Because as another
speaker in this series,
Noam Chomsky, said--
I'm not quoting verbatim--
but the ideas that grammar--
the broad concepts of
grammar are the same--
generally the same from
one language to another.
And when you master
those, you just
have to add some unique
pieces for each language.
AUDIENCE: So you intrigued
me with your untranslatable
statements about books.
I'm curious how you
define that or what
makes a book untranslatable?
LAURA ESTHER WOLFSON: What
makes it look untranslatable?
Well, I can only
say for myself what
makes a book untranslatable
because other people then went
on and translated those books
that I declined to translate.
I think as a
translator, you have
to believe that everything
is translatable.
Otherwise, you're a fraud.
But as a person who knows more
than one language and more
than one culture, you know
that it's not possible.
So you have to live
with that contradiction.
In my-- well,
literary translators
like to say that you
can only translate
those books that you've
fallen in love with.
And I didn't fall in love
with any of those books
that I turned down.
So I guess that's
the first condition
because literary translation
is not remunerative at all.
It's the worst paid
form of translation.
I turned down books because
there were things about them
that I felt I didn't
fully understand.
As it happens, the books
that I write about here
that I decided not to translate
were all oral history.
They did not have difficult
words or idioms in them,
but I felt that I would
not be able to capture
the unique voice
of the speakers.
One of them contained many,
many different speakers,
and I didn't know how I was
going to contrast them all.
They all felt different.
And I did a sample
of a few pages,
and I felt like everything
that I did was correct,
but there was something
about it that was not right.
Later I found out
that the person
who had done the oral history--
in different
versions of the book,
she actually attributed the same
passages to different speakers.
So my concern-- I was
apparently more conscientious
than she was.
But there are also words
that are untranslatable.
Somebody asked this for
an interview recently.
What's the word-- what's
a word in Russian that's
untranslatable?
And I answered, there was
a word that I encountered
on one of my first big
stays in the Soviet Union
when it was still
the Soviet Union.
The word is [SPEAKS RUSSIAN].
The root is [SPEAKS RUSSIAN],,
which means table.
[SPEAKS RUSSIAN],, the
suffix, means around.
And then the last
part [SPEAKS RUSSIAN]
just indicates that
it's an abstract noun.
So this word
literally means that
which goes on around a table.
But it means
something like feast
plus banquet plus all the
conversation, speech making,
toasts, drinking,
singing, and the bonds
that are arising between--
among all people around
the table and all the work
that went into putting
out that spread
all in one word in a culture
where feasting and gathering
is very, very important.
And it also usually signifies
a private family or friends
event, not an official event.
So how do you put that
all into one English word?
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
draw a parallel that I'm
a little embarrassed to make.
As with many people here, I
write software for a living.
And one of the
things about software
is that it's never done.
You can always go back and
polish it and improve it.
And your writing seems--
your style of writing
seems to be the same,
that however much effort
you put into it, however
carefully you craft it, you can
always go back and change it.
How do you know
when you're done?
I know when I'm done because
the deadline has passed.
But how do you know when you're
writing when you're done?
LAURA ESTHER WOLFSON: How
do I know when I'm done?
Well, there was a French
poet who said no work of art
is ever done, only abandoned.
I do tend to
procrastinate by spending
a great deal of time polishing.
That's a nice word for it.
Oscar Wilde said, I
spent the day writing.
I spent the morning
putting in a comma,
and then I spent the
afternoon taking it out.
I don't know how I'm done.
For this book, there
were revision deadlines.
But when I was
writing the pieces
over the course of years,
nobody was waiting for them.
I think that I was
producing about 40--
35 or 40 publishable pages
for many years, a tiny amount.
And I guess when I just felt
that I'd spent enough time
polishing and I wasn't adding
anything substantively new,
then I would stop.
But they're never finished
until they're bound.
Raymond Carver used to get his
books from his publisher just
published, and he would
take out pencil and start
correcting the finished book.
I'm tempted to do
that sometimes.
Thank you very.
[APPLAUSE]